good morning John one thing we do not
talk a lot about here on vlogbrothers is
math but I'm about to show you a very
low stakes math problem that you don't
have to get right that did change the
way that I see the social internet when
the last vestiges of my timetable still
holding on I initially realized that
each of the numbers on the right was a
multiple of the ones on the left from
there I realized that there was a
pattern 9 times 10 is 90 8 times 9 is 72
7 times 8 is 56 6 times 7 is 42. great
so what is three this math question went
viral on Twitter because people were
arguing about what three is you may have
even been Snappy enough to form an
opinion yourself a lot of people said it
was 12. a lot of people said it was 18.
the 12 people and the 18 people were
arguing with each other and they were
all very certain that they were right
team 18 pointed out that there was a
sequence of numbers being multiplied ten
nine eight seven and then the next
number six would be six times three
which would be eighteen twelve said that
every number is being multiplied by
itself plus one nine times ten six times
seven and so three times four is twelve
watching people on Twitter argue about
this was a little like having sand
thrown into my eyes because of course
there are two correct answers to this
question and neither of them is 12 or
18. the two correct answers are either
12 or 18 not 12 or 18 but 12 or 18. or
the second correct answer is the
question is wrong but here's the thing
to me the right answer is 12. because n
times n plus 1 just seems more mathy to
me than a sequence being multiplied by
the numbers but
that's not right in this situation
everyone who believes their answer is
right is wrong the only people who are
right are the ones who know they don't
know now with math problems when they
are unclear you know that it's a poorly
created math problem but with almost
every other kind of problem you know
that if it is unclear that's actually a
pretty good sign that it's a real
problem like if it's clear how to solve
it it's probably not that big of a
problem but I learned something else
very interesting from this confounding
incorrect math problem which I started
to learn when I noticed that people were
talking about this rather than every
other math problem there's nothing
interesting about a math problem
everyone agrees on one of the very few
reasons that math goes viral is when
people fight like this mess of an
equation that I see all the time it
might seem to a person like me that this
would be an important math problem
because it comes up a lot but
mathematicians don't think this problem
is interesting they wouldn't try to
answer that question they would ask for
it to be Rewritten and so if vague
questions that are easy to argue about
mislead us into Imagining the world
incorrectly I it's important to ask why
these questions are easy to argue about
and here's why it's not just that people
believe different things in this
situation it's that it is easy to
believe different things looking at this
problem it is as easy to know that the
answer is 12 as it is to know that the
answer is 18. a question like that is
bound to get some attention whether it
is about math or guns or immigration
particularly it will get a lot of
questions from people who don't know
that much about it because experts are
aware that the problem is poorly phrased
and badly done and so aren't really
interfacing with it but for the rest of
us these are situations where it's very
easy to have one of several different
opinions that are not the same answer
questions like that due to the nature of
humanity and its algorithms are gonna be
the ones we're most likely to see and
that's going to drive wedges and not
just in the way that we usually think
where it's like between two big
political parties but also within
political parties within communities
within people who broadly agree with
each other on almost everything they
just don't notice because those aren't
the interesting things when if the
question was asked in a more complete
way we wouldn't find it interesting
because we'd all agree vague questions
that lead to the formation of simple
opinions that are likely to conflict
with the opinions of others are much
more likely to create conflict and thus
much more likely to go viral and also
very often the answers to those
questions are invalid because the
questions themselves are wrong John I
will see you on Tuesday